hello here steve kaufmann I continue
the series on the seven secrets
of language learning
well it was first spent
enough time to be
successful to succeed in
language learning
secondly to do
pleasant things things that we like
thirdly to pay
attention to what is happening in my
language
fourthly fourthly that
vocabulary is more important than
grammar and fifthly 5th secret
is to remain patient with patients
as the case may be because learning a
language
takes time  time there are ups and
downs very often we have the impression that we
are not making progress very often we
learn things that we later on we
forget one day we think that we are comparing there
it is good that  'we were able to communicate what
we wanted to say etc.
then the next few days we have a lot of
trouble explaining ourselves to express ourselves and it
's sometimes while studying our bed we
listen to something even like  me aline
that there is a lot of text with
audio and text we read it we understand it
we listen we don't understand and it's
always the same place that we do
n't understand so there are a lot of situations
like that  part of the very
gradual progress in
language learning is all the time you
spend listening studying reading etc all of this
helps
because little by little the
vassal brain gets used to the language but if
you have feelings  frustration
negative feelings
it harms learning because there
is the emotional side of learning
so anything that is positive feeling
I want I can
the language pleases me all of this helps you to
take and anything that is negative I
can't imagine blier again
it's been a long time since i
studied english then it seems like i
'm not making any progress all this you do
n't have to try to avoid this kind of
feeling so you have to have some
patience you must not let
yourself be fru  stré so this is my fifth
secret of language learning
thank you and goodbye